sin funerales de estado debido a la
situación sanitaria
la procesión funeraria de hemos
enfatizado ha sido difundida por el
canal estatal iraní así como la visita
del ministro de defensa su viuda
el científico murió el viernes cerca de
teherán en un ataque no reivindicado su
muerte ha desatado la ira de numerosos
iraníes y muchos han salido a
manifestarse a pesar de las medidas
sanitarias que nuestra sangre está en
ebullición y no descansaremos hasta que
no hayamos obtenido la revancha por la
muerte de mohsén a causa de una llamada
a la venganza difundida por twitter por
el ayatolá jamenéi que ha llamado a
represalias para el gobierno iraní el
asesinato lleva la firma de israel hemos
enfatizado fue el jefe del programa
nuclear iraní entre 1989 y 2003 y estaba
acusado por eeuu israel de seguir con su
actividad pese al acuerdo nuclear el
gobierno israelí no ha hecho
declaraciones sobre el ataque pero ha
puesto a sus embajadas en estado de
alerta